so the president trying to steer clear
of democrats calls to defund the police
trying to distance himself with as crime
surges and some of the liberal policies
come under fire listen to this
the answer is not to abandon our streets
that's not the answer the answer is not
to defund the police
it's to give you the tools the training
the funding
to be partners to be protectors we're
not about defunding we're about funding
okay so the president's attempt to pivot
on crime putting him at odds with the
far left and his own vice president
we have to reimagine public safety
and how we do public safety in our
country not only do we need to defund
but we need to dismantle and start a new
talking about um the reduction of our
nypd budget and defunding a 6 billion
nypd budget i am for defunding the
police yes i support the defund movement
because this is about the
the um
investment
in our communities which have
historically been divested
so that that really didn't work out very
well um we have increasing crime
homicide rape uh car theft is up 92
percent in cities all over the country
um so janine what did you think about
what the president said when he came to
town and what he focused on
well
i didn't think much of what he said
because this is a president who was
quiet during 2020
when the streets were burning down and
when they told us you know that these
were peaceful protests with buildings
coming down police precincts being
emptied federal courthouse being uh
bombed and uh and arson being committed
there you know they're literally just
they talk out of both sides of their
mouth but let's talk about the focus he
talked about guns and he talked about
bringing the feds in i'm going to bring
the feds in and they're going to handle
all these gun crimes i said the other
day the feds across the nation have
handled in 50 states a grand total of 12
000 gun crimes but he said we can now
work together we're thinking of ways to
work together what are you thinking
about we've been working together for
years the state the feds are local i was
a d.a we put together task forces we
don't need you to come to new york and
tell us this but here's the problem the
problem is that they're all talk whether
it's hocal whether it's adams and i want
to give adams the benefit of the doubt
and whether it is a president i'll tell
you why with adams adams said
yesterday i don't control bail reform
but we need to give judges the
dangerousness component and raise the
age or part of it and i don't control
that because they're federal laws
are you stupid they're not federal laws
these are state laws that you can
control that you can change that you can
appeal they're all full of it they don't
have a moral core
and richard you know what is the
argument against that those are two
things bail reform give judges the right
to look at an individual give them
discretion the right to look at what's
going on say you know what you do not
deserve to be on the street you have
committed seven crimes beforehand now
you're back in front of me again you're
going away tonight and you're gonna wait
for your court date or to say that
anyone under the age of 18 shouldn't be
prosecuted i mean do you know how many
16 15 year olds are stealing cars all
over new york all over new jersey all
over long island washington dc all over
the place so are those rules that should
be changed well listen i think we've had
this conversation on your show before
martha and i i agree with you on that
particular point uh where i do agree
with the met with the mayor of new york
why didn't the president say it why
doesn't he back it
and i think he does i mean he doesn't
control the bill he doesn't control the
bail laws i think where with what the
gov what the mayor is trying to say in
new york is it's on the state
legislature to determine what the bill
is but i want to point to a police
department say that he said it's on the
floor and that was there was a
misstatement on his point right but i
want to let's talk about standing where
it's working so in the city of st louis
uh mayor to share jones um a city that
had what was the deadliest city in the
country she did something that was
actually pretty remarkable she created a
three-prong strategy deterrence
intervention and prevention the first
part is she created a program called
cops and clinicians and in that program
in the highest crime neighborhoods they
pair up cops with clinicians social
workers psychiatrists and they bring
them into crime situations so that these
clinicians can de-escalate the second
thing she did is she created the she she
hired in its people people who live in
community to intervene in crimes helping
folks find jobs when crimes happen
de-escalating those crimes and the third
thing she did was she pushed the police
officers to solve unsolved murders as a
result of that in saint louis the
homicide rate is down 26 percent crime
is down 10 percent so if we do some of
the policies that democrats and all
people with common sense have advocated
for there's not all calls that police
officers should show up to i've spent 24
hours with the cop and they're cops to
tell you but we don't want to show up to
drug crimes because when people are
having a drug overdose we're not the
best trained to deal with it but a drug
therapist is
so to send a therapist to that apartment
where those two cops were killed exactly
exactly
that was a domestic violence call and
what you're saying is send a socialist
but it's working in saint louis but if
there's so much homicides are down
you know how high the homicides were
when this started and it broke down
under 26
that's progress
remember where you're starting
remember what we're starting but you you
have to acknowledge that they're down 26
yeah congratulations
how far were they up before they went
but it doesn't matter it shows that the
policies work what the policies have i i
just i just
work their assault codes after cold
cases everybody does that well good for
her jesse
i don't know i'm gonna have to look at
the statistics in the commercial break
we'll see if that's accurate but biden's
trying to win an argument that his party
already lost to defund the police
argument's dead they lost that so he
thinks he's winning he's losing because
he's on defense against the squad and
he's on defense against republicans
there's two questions that joe biden
needs to answer and the media has to
press him on that one
if you are an ex-con and you commit a
felony should you be able to get out on
no or low bail yes or no mr president
the other question is do you believe
armed robbery should be a misdemeanor
yes or no mr president if he tries to
wiggle you hit him with a specific case
and ask him if he's comfortable with
that the problem is the media doesn't
ask about crime they ask about ukraine
crime an entire news conference not one
person asked a question on crime right
we want to add we want the answers to
this question and the longer joe biden
is silent on those things he gives air
cover to da's and local legislatures to
keep putting
bad people back on the streets right
yeah i
on this defunding thing i will hold a
grudge i'm not going to forget the
reprehensible movement because it
directly affected me unlike it affected
politicians or the media it still
affects me we had another smash and grab
in my neighborhood yesterday i think
about how the media and and the
democrats defending and helping
looters and rioters under the guise of
justice i will not forget that we need
to hang defund the police around every
democrat's neck and they're going to say
but wait i wasn't pro defend the police
but yo you didn't have the guts to speak
up biden didn't have the guts to speak
up he was he was hiding like a coward
and just by not saying anything he
enabled these wacky destructive deadly
policies you know and by not saying
anything they also helped the massive
demonization of police that we saw
happen which contributed to the ferguson
effect which caused the murder rate to
go up it's important that the democrats
feel the pain for creating this climate
and people should not forget last thing
the aloofness of the media and the
politicians about crime speaks to the
fact that they don't experience it so
what does the reporters do those heroic
reporters they show up and they report
on the protests they gin it up until
there are riots and there's arson and
then they leave they don't return to
minneapolis they don't see if anything's
been rebuilt they're god they don't know
anything there's nobody smashing and
grabbing in their neighborhoods so what
do they care there's nobody being pushed
in front of subways where they live so
they don't care so they have to be held
accountable and as far as i will never
forget
2019 and 2020 2020 when all this stuff
started
never forget never forget the policies
and the numbers don't lie yeah they
don't lie hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else